COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of "Cloud Performance Atlas,"
we help some global image
crunchers bring their costs
down using preemptive VMs.
Will we get their performance
out of this world?
Stay tuned to find out.
[ELECTRONIC TONES]
SkyEYE is a research
organization
who's focused on the
health of the planet
by processing digital
imagery from satellites.
They came to me with
a massive problem.
As a seed funded startup,
they were having trouble
keeping their core hours
down, since processing
a petabyte of image
data on a regular basis
was a huge undertaking
and was a lot of costs.
Their system grabs
satellite imagery
and pushes the image
information to cloud storage,
while pushing the metadata to
data store for retrieval later.
They also have a
notification system set up
when images are uploaded
to the GCS bucket
which creates a Pub/Sub
message containing details
about where to find the image.
This Pub/Sub message is then
pulled by an auto scaling
instance group which grabs the
image, data store information,
and starts processing
the image data.
All the results are
pushed to BigQuery
where they can search, sort,
and analyze the results.
Now, at this point, we ran
down the list of topics.
We checked how the instance
groups were performing,
what their startup time looked
like, and the performance
of their nodes individually.
Turns out, one of
their engineers
was a fan of our video series.
So all the stuff that we
would normally recommend
was already fixed--
thanks for watching--
which meant that they
weren't doing anything wrong.
They just had a ton of work and
needed to keep the cost down,
which is why I pointed
them on the direction
of preemptive VMs.
Preemptive VMs are the
same as regular instances,
except for one key difference--
Compute Engine might
terminate these instances
if it requires access to those
resources for other tasks,
which can happen at any time.
Now, I know what
you're thinking.
That sounds mega disruptive.
But they have one upside--
[TRUMPET FLOURISH]
By not guaranteeing
indefinite up time,
Google is able to
offer preemptive VMs
at a substantial discount
to normal instances, which
means they may not be a fit
for all of your architecture,
but there may be parts
of your cloud application
which they are ideal for.
For SkyEYE, converting
over to preemptive VMS
was pretty simple.
It started by flipping
the preemptive flag
in their instance template.
And then they made
modifications to handle
the preemptive events.
See, before a PVM
can be shut down,
it has to signal your
instance ahead of time,
giving your app time to
respond and clear local data
before things get lost.
For the design that SkyEYE was
doing, this was really simple.
Since they were doing
a Pub/Sub stream,
they just didn't
acknowledge the receipt
and let another VM in the
group pick up that work
and do it on their behalf.
SkyEYE shifted over and recently
completed a massive experiment
using almost 30,000 CPUs to
process one petabyte of imagery
in just 16 hours, all
using preemptive VMs
and saving some serious coin.
To learn more about the perf
details of these buckets,
check out the article linked
in the description below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of our "Cloud
Performance Atlas"
content, because when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]